hey most Americans want an investigation
into Trump Russia connections there's a
new NBC Wall Street Journal poll which
found that 53% of Americans agreed that
Congress should investigate contact
between Russia and President Donald
Trump's team 25% of those who responded
to this poll believe that Congress
should stay out of it and 21% didn't
have an opinion highly partisan 80% of
Democrats thought that Russia ties
should be investigated 25 percent of
Republicans believed that Russia tithe
should be investigated basically
identical numbers when asked whether
Congress should investigate Russia's
attempts to interfere in the election
generally 54% of Americans agreed 29
percent did not these right-wingers the
blind trumpets don't they need to start
thinking as Americans rather than as
Republicans or Democrats I was hugely
critical of the references to the world
war two nativist talking point of
America first when Trump used it at his
inauguration speech but if you do want
to think about putting America at the
top of your sort of list of priorities
don't you have to put aside partisanship
and realize that this is something very
serious that should be investigated
especially because this investigation
would just bring out new information I
mean who could possibly be opposed to
that
even if you're a trump supporter you
want to have that and it's nothing like
Benghazi I would say because they had
nine different investigations into
Benghazi yeah we're only looking for one
here Obama was a Russian Communist with
no evidence Russia was the worst when
Mitt Romney said it in 2012 the biggest
threat all of a sudden now that we have
mountains of evidence about Russia being
involved with Donald Trump and with our
elections now all of a sudden Russia's
fine stop the Red Scare you lefties
Russia's no problem whatsoever
and by the way if it emerged that Barack
Obama had potentially been compromised
by the Russians you would not have 20%
sorry
25% of the population blindly supporting
Obama you just wouldn't and it's gone
beyond being cult-like I've actually met
a couple of people Pat who would
probably be in that 25 percent and
rationalize the entire Russia Trump
thing away with phrases like let's let
the president do his job or why does
everything in Washington have to be an
argument or a disagreement or a debate
these happen to be the same people who
desperately want to see President
Obama's or wanted to see President
Obama's birth certificate and then once
it was released they said they didn't
believe that the birth certificate was
legitimate the difference of course was
that there was never any actual evidence
that President Obama wasn't born in the
US and we have binders full of evidence
that Trump and Russia are Bigley
connected if you think these supporters
are playing politics the politicians
definitely are jason Chaffetz who is the
investigator in chief you could say
looked into all of these different
things that Hillary Clinton potentially
committed yeah he Trump he's not even
gonna touch him and last week we
actually said that in the midst of the
Russia craziness jason Chaffetz has
decided to open an investigation into
some national parks Twitter account but
hey but we don't have to worry about
what's going on here 2002 2008
Republicans were saying hey we just have
to listen and follow what George W Bush
is doing I mean he is the president
after all let's respect the office of
the President 2008 to 2016 or I guess
2009 to 2017 if you want to be technical
about it F Obama he's a foreigner his
birth certificates fake he's a Kenyan
Indonesian British Muslim terrorist
Donald Trump is inaugurated January 20th
of 2017 hey listen we just have to
listen respectfully to what Donald Trump
says he is the president after all we
have to respect the office of the
president bogus absolutely and utterly
bogus make sure to discuss these stories
or any others that you're interested in
on our reddit discussion forum at david
pakman.com slash read it also please
please please follow me on instagram i
am on instagram at david pakman and a
lot happening on that Instagram page on
the bonus show today I think people are
going to be interested in this story Pat
over the weekend there was a David
Pakman show sort of gathering which we
can talk about on the bonus show and
afterwards Pat and I and a couple of
other people witnessed what I would
consider a relatively major car accident
I've actually not witnessed I've seen
like driving by the high
way bigger car accidents but I've never
seen this level of a car accident happen
in front of me right I mean I've been in
car accidents never caused by me I might
add that's good but I've never gone by
and seen two other cars or one car in
this case crash in anyway yeah so we're
going to talk about that we're going to
talk about the action I took and we're
going to also talk about spat Pat's
scepticism about the action that I
decided to take in reaction to this car
accident that we saw also SpaceX Elon
Musk of SpaceX fame has teased an
announcement that we would be getting
tomorrow from SpaceX I have speculation
about what it might be we will see if
patent agrees we will see if the
audience agrees how do you get access to
the bonus show it's quite simple really
all David Pakman show members regardless
of whether you sign up at full price or
at a discounted price get instant access
to all of the member benefits which
include the bonus show as well as the
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show and lots of other great
member benefits to sign up here's how
you do it david pakman.com slash
membership we have monthly memberships
we have yearly memberships this is the
number one funding source for the show
if you don't want to pay full price we
have a coupon code available for you
that coupon code is all one word all
lowercase
I voted 17 you select any membership you
want at david pakman.com slash
membership and then after clicking the
sign up button you will have the
opportunity to enter a coupon code and
that coupon code is I voted 17 and it
will give you I don't think it's an
exaggeration Pat to call it a big league
discount off of membership I'm
comfortable saying that that's good
that's very good all right Pat seems
comfortable as well which is good we
don't want to have a lack of comfort for
things you to do yeah absolutely Pat
seems pretty comfortable over there okay
so please sign up great bonus show today
bonus shows are happening we will talk
to you then
or on tomorrow's program